Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Spider-Man Q&A.
Whole bunch of questions about how he fits
into the avengers are we can see defender
so I try to include as much stuff as possible.
There's going to be a whole bunch more Spider-Man
and Guardians stuff happening during the break.
So make sure you click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss out on anything so
here we go Joven asks what your thoughts
on the Spider-Man logo being red and yellow
a connection to Iron Man hint to iron spider anything
different from his comic book branding do
I think there's going to be just a little
bit of winking at the iron spider, but the
Suit that you see him and for most of that the
Civil War suit will probably be the only suit that
he wears the one exception to that is the
hoodie that he wears in part of the trailer.
The film will probably jump around in time.
So will probably see him before Civil War
were he's wearing the goggles in the hoodie
then after Civil War when iron man's like
yeah, you could totally keep the suit, but
it does not mean that you are an avenger.
So the red on yellow is just a little bit
of eye winking about Marvel and Spider-Man coming
together in the presence of Iron Man in the
film so it gets a little meta-but I don't
think he's going to be wearing the actual
iron spider suit.
Most people think of when they think iron
spider next question al tep asks was that Kraven
please help me.
So no there's no Kraven in this movie
but I do think that they'll use him in the
trilogy at some point the person you're thinking
of is the vulture, it's Michael Keaton wearing
his jacket with the fur around the collar
like that's his vulture jacket.
So that's what he looks a little bit like
Kraven, just because he has that big collar
next one smooth says kingpin is rumored to
be in this movie, so I don't think there's
going to be any kingpin in the actual movie.
But Vincent D'Onofrio did say he would love
to be in Spider-Man.
The funny thing about that is that everybody
wants to be in the Spider-Man felt like he
is the Clark Gregg sitting off in the distance,
waving his hand.
Please put me in the Spider-Man movie this
to be so much fun.
So what I think is can happen is is if they
ever work kingpin into a Spider-Man movie.
It'll just be at Easter egg level.
You'll hear about the kingpin of crime, but
he'll stay relatively local to Manhattan you
won't hear about him so much out in Queens
where Spider-Man spends most of his time next
question Robert asks do you think will do
spider verse with the other live-action Spiderman
like Andrew Garfield Toby McGuire no I don't
think that they're going to do that.
But as for other spider people silk is in
the movie the character who turns into silk
in the comics is in, but they might not necessarily
do that.
The thing about Spider-Man is that he's one
of the most popular, comic book characters
of all time.
That means that there are a ton of characters
in the spider verse.
So there's no way they'll have time to get
to them all in the movies, but with characters
like Ned Leeds they might not do hobgoblin
with characters like silk they might not actually
have her put the costume on, but they totally
exist in that universe is just the problem
is is the more characters you stuff in the
last time you had to spend developing other
characters.
So I'm not expecting miles morales or spider
gwen or silk or even venom to put costumes
on in any the movies but like we could totally
see Eddie Brock show up next question
Shafkat asks what you think vulture's motivation
for being a villain is well there are a couple
things that happen to him in the comics that
they could include in the movie there was
a business partner that stole all his money
so he had to turn to crime but he also later
in the comics had a grandson with a medical
condition.
So he was forced to steal to get the money
for his medical treatments so they could go
any number of different directions, but the
way Michael Keaton comes off in the trailer.
He seems vicious.
So maybe he had a family member that died.
He has a daughter in the comics so maybe his
daughter died because of something the avengers
did that seems like the thing that they been
going with since Civil War like the avengers
because collateral damage and everybody hates
them now next question though Fenix asks is
there any actor playing Norman Osborne not
as far as we know it seems like they're holding
off on the Osborne stuff.
The stuff you seen a whole bunch of in the
other movies just because they might not be
in this first movie though doesn't mean that
they won't ever do green goblin stuff.
I think is just taking their time.
So maybe by the third movie they'll loop them
back in because that'll be almost 6 years
down the road.
They've already dated the second Spider-Man
movie for Fourth of July weekend 2019.
So if production stays on track and within
about four years we could see more green goblin
think one of the big criticisms has been then
just redoing the same story and Spider-Man
movies the origin story over and over overreliance
on the same types of characters so the try
to do something completely different with
this first movie, but that does mean there
never going to do those other characters again
like Mary Jane or Gwen Stacy next question,
follow-up to that Dakota asks can you discuss
the possibility of Gwen or MJ in the sequels
would you like to see play those roles will
there is a rumor that Mary Jane is in the
movie but in a very backdoor secretive kind
of way.
The thing about those characters is is are
so fundamental to the Spider-Man character
that you kinda have to do them like you to
get away with not doing green goblin.
There's so many.
Spider-Man villains that you can make the
main villain of the movie.
But there really only a handful of characters
that are very close to the Peter Parker character
and because he's in high school.
He hangs out with his friends all the time.
So he would run into those people pretty quickly.
So I will say I do think that Mary Jane is
somewhere in Spider-Man homecoming, but we
won't learn about it to like the very end
of the film.
It'll be something really offhanded like oh
my God she's been here this whole time.
We didn't realize it but if you're worried
about them not being anywhere in there.
Don't worry.
They're just not can include them in any of
the marketing for the movie next question
gaming speedster asks what other upgrades
you think.
Spider-Man got so I think is just you know
utility belt like little things that make
him seem more like comic book Spider-Man the
suit is extra durable it holds more gear more
wedding cartridges it probably helps him with
a couple cool trick shots with his wedding
like look at this big scene here were he's
trying to hold this boat together.
This is crazy.
So the materials that Stark used to build
the suit are much more advanced than the stuff
that he was using for his homemade suit.
So like his wedding is probably just as strong
as the wedding that he originally made but
his homemade gauntlets would probably get
crushed under the stress of all this weight.
So the Stark tech suit is just a much stronger
version of the comic book costume and you
can also kind of see his eyes open and dilate
like the eyes move little bit like Deadpool's
eyes moved in that movie with CG, but because
it Stark tech to more like camera irises.
I think a really good examples when he's fighting
the fake avengers.
You see his eyes move wait a minute you authorial
like he doesn't need to tell the suit to open
the irises, they just automatically receive
on his muscle contractions.
So the easiest explanation is just expect
the eyes to work a lot like Deadpool's eyes
during that movie next question's and master
asks what would Tony means by other people
is talking about shield Street heroes like
the defenders.
Does he mean Capt. America secret avengers
really he just talking about the adults like
the adults will handle this.
You go to school and be a kid if you really
want to dig into that yeah I mean shield does
exist it's aboveboard now.
So technically they be the ones to respond
to that but if anyone he's talking about the
actual avengers like he says Peter isn't a
real avenger yet.
Don't worry the adults the avengers will handle
stuff like that.
You go on and be a kid.
Have fun go to school.
He seems to have a great interest in Peter
just continuing to be a kid.
So that's like the worst possible advice you
could give to teenage Peter Parker of course
he wants to prove himself and be a hero.
So there's no way he's gonna listen, Iron
Man next question Spencer asks.
I'm seeing a fair amount Iron Man in the trailer
but when arm is flying next to him.
I'm wondering how large a part he's going
to play, I still want this to be a Spider-Man
movie.
So that's totally true it is a Spider-Man
movie Iron Man just going to be in part of
it, you can see how they want to hike the
movie up as much as possible, so the gonna
put as much Iron Man as they possibly can
into those trailers, so I will be willing
to bet that the scenes that we saw with the
exception of like a big final battle where
Iron Man helps out that's pretty much every
scene, Iron Man is in the movie like when
he drops them off when he gives him the talking
to at the avengers base look kit let the adults
handle this.
And then when he's flying through the neighborhood
with them your maybe like a little bit more,
but it is gonna be like a tutu and 1/2 hour
movie I be willing to bet that there's as
little as like 20 minutes of Iron Man the
movie which is about how much Spider-Man was
in Civil War there's probably as much Iron
Man in the Spider-Man movie as Spider-Man
was in Civil War next question Israel asks
do you think that will see any connections
to the defender show or any of the Netflix
series maybe somebody confusing them for daredevil
because they both wear red suit, but that's
about it like Easter egg level they been really
tightlipped about what's going on with the
defenders as of the Avengers infinity war.
So don't if they want to shoehorn in any defenders
if were not actually going to see them moving
around in the be relatively localized to Manhattan
you have iron fist happening in Manhattan
proper have Hells kitchen.
You have Harlem there's very little going
on in Queens.
That's primarily where most of Spider-Man
is gonna take place so best case scenario
somebody confuses him for daredevil the guy
in the red suit like you hear people talk
about a man in a red suit saving people in
the Spider-Man like no that's not me that's
that's another guy's one already talked about
kingpin though that would actually be a really
bad ass crossover just because he's such a
big Spider-Man character in the comics but
thank you so much everyone for dropping questions
is always a ton of fun to do.
I'm not expecting another trailer at least
until the Super Bowl.
But the pride drops of teasers before then
there will be Spider-Man giveaways happening
every week like I'll just keep doing it to
where the be plenty bonus videos.
So I will say congratulations to the first
winner Amel daikon you and a comics all and
she giftcard please private message me on
the back and my channel so I can get your
contact details.
So what can happen tomorrow is The Walking
Dead finale's happenings will do a video for
that the be some game of thrones and then
will be more comic book stuff happening on
Monday while you guys wait for that to post
you can click here to rewatch the Spider-Man
trailers again and you can click here for
the trailer for the next episode of the flash
thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!